[Music]
I forgot pretty much laid it all out the
last time I saw tomorrow so I have no
questions I have nothing to say I have
no emotions if he's there great and if
he has anything to say I'll listen but I
said my piece and then you said peace
what did you think about that whole
bachelor in paradise thing did you hear
about it and did you did you have like a
thought about it I mean I wasn't there
so it's like I've learned a long time
ago I don't have an opinion on something
I didn't hear or see myself I consider
Kareena friend but I don't have any
opinions on it because it's not really a
good friend I mean yeah I consider her a
friend you know I would tell you any
other way if you know what I like to say
is you only get a snippet of a person I
get to know her in depth and I really do
like her eats he caught up with the
Bachelorette Rachel Lindsay at the ESPYs
on Wednesday night I went to the
University of Texas I've already run
into one Longhorns Eric Johnson just
walk through
[Music]
you